hello it today I'm Jeff I don't and
we've been trying to do this video for a
long time last time we tried it this
happened 109 yeah you did so now we've
done is we've changed location we got
more powerful cooker and it's really
windy which makes it even more dangerous
than the last time we did it so
basically this video is what not to do
in an oil fire situation if you have a
load of oil that's on fire don't throw
water on it because the water sinks
through the oil evaporates immediately
on the surface of the pan and throws all
the oil upwards in a big flaming hot and
melty mess so burn yeah not you won't
burn so I'm taking some more precautions
it's done with a face mask
yeah I'm standing upwind of quiet
alright get that oil on
that's enough buddy oh yeah it's on fire
oh yeah get approached mean out there
[Music]
you
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dan that looks amazing yes unbelievable
amazing / terrifying scary you may have
noticed that we're actually five
thousand miles away from where we shot
that video but it's quieter here and
it's lena wind our original audio was
wind noise so we're doing another outro
if you want to put out an oil fire don't
throw water on it soak a towel dish
towel or a tea towel put it over the top
of the pan and should go out also don't
sort of pour the oil onto your hand like
I did in the previous video don't do
that right there that was right over
there yeah don't do that feel free to
use this in a fire training educational
video if you see this and want to use it
that's fine follow us on Twitter if you
want buy a shirt hello I've got three
shirts and we will see you in the next
video thanks for watching
[Music]
how's your scar now yeah it's not so
good Oh knows this huh
hello you can see this bill lets her
let's have a close-up just like this
circle here's the main yeah held up well
yeah not bad
I'm impressed with it